Yeah. Um, man,
it's going to be a weird world
when our kids are our age.
It's going to be a weird,
weird world. I mean,
I don't even think we could
begin to comprehend it.
I think we'd be totally guessing.
Think there's some shit that's
coming around the corner.
Do you see that NASA,
Tom Delonge thing?
Everybody keeps harassing me
about um, the uh, the video,
the Ufo. I'm here, I'm reading are
turning up more videos all day long.
I'll be like not just one
video. Let's see. Let me see.
One of them videos is Tom delonge
putting out videos and know his,
his organization is putting out
videos of you. Fos. Yeah. And it's,
I'm a fighter pilot and f a 18,
I believe is chasing this thing and
it's showing all the details of like the
Lao, the altitude, how fast it's going,
what pitch it's at and all that jazz.
I don't know what that means, what pitches
hot, but they're watching this thing,
they're trying to figure out what it is.
One of the guys is like, it's a drone.
It's gotta be some kind of a drone.
They see something and it turns,
it was going very fast. Basically.
It's like all the other Ufo,
but it should not worry.
Yeah, it's blurry.
It's in like a gun sites or like,
you know,
some sort of a infrared site rather.
Um,
so you're looking at it through this
weird infrared video where it doesn't
necessarily look, you know,
it's weird. It's weird. You're
looking at it like, okay,
what am I looking at? I'm
looking at it. A little object.
Do you remember that quote?
It could be a total bullshit quote
from Warner von Braun. He, uh,
that he said right before he died that,
uh,
beware of the fake alien invasion.
Did he say that in so many words?
I hope he did. I hope he did it.
He did it just to fuck with people.
It's amazing flying around. There's a
whole fleet of, I'm looking at my asa
gotcha. Oh, going against the wind.
The wind's a hustle west,
so they're following it for a while
and then it changes direction.
It's rotating.
So whatever that is,
whatever that is.
Is Vr fucking super interesting. And, uh,
I heard the now going to shoo fly Travis
Barker to Washington DC to talk to
people and give him some
information as well. No neck.
They're gonna fly Kanye West.
He,
they're going to fly him out and show
him the secret lab for real. No. Oh,
I'm making this up because I think
it's crazy flying Tom delonge I know.
I might not be fake. It might
be real. It could be it. Look,
here's the thing about aliens, right? How
often do you think they'd have to visit?
I think they could get it done once
in the 70s and be done with us.
They check us out and they'd be
a look at these crazy ass holes.
This is what we're going
to do. We're going to, uh,
we're going to install some cameras
on the moon. These stupid fuckers,
they won't even be able to see it.
We'll just put some big ass cameras to
film them from the distance and let's get
out of here.
These people are crazy like this.
They're going to have nuclear power
with these assholes and they just would
never see them again.
So like if that really is a Ufo,
if it really is from
another planet rather,
how many times they have to come here,
you don't, I mean if they are real,
how much evidence would
you really see of him?
Would you see it once every 10 years?
How are, how often would they come about?
Was it you?
Maybe someone had a joke that like maybe
this is like the [inaudible] of the
university and this is the deal.
A lot of outer space really come down
here when they're fucked up and they want
to see a show. Was that party? Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. That was a whole, yeah,
that's super old. It's 2000 early.
Two thousands yeah. I think it's,
I'm not a nonbeliever that's for fuck.
Shoer I think it's entirely possible.
Like if, if I looked up in the
sky and an alien ship flew by,
I would never think there's no way that
can't be real. It can't be possible.
I would think. Wow, they
fucking, they visited us.
I mean I'm sure there's something out
there that's smart. I'm sure there is.
It's a matter of what it would look like.
You know what?
It even be in a physical form
anymore. I mean, why do we assume,
we assume that everything has to be in a
physical form? What are you looking at?
Kendrick Lamar says he saw a Ufo,
but nobody believes them.